bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors est ce que pour vous
cette proposition de loi sécurité
globale et ce qu'elle vise effectivement
un finalement mettre en place un arsenal
d'outils pour restreindre à la fois les
libertés publiques et amplifier la
répression comme le soulignent les
détracteurs du texte il ya une réalité
qui est toujours la même c'est comment
est-ce qu'on utilise un arsenal qu'on
met en place effectivement que vous avez
aujourd'hui des textes qui sont pointés
du doigt y compris au niveau européen
parce que c'est quand même assez étrange
et s'interpellent de voir que c'est
effectivement à compter de l'europe qui
invite gentiment le sénat a retiré la 24
de cette loi en disant vous ne pouvez
pas objectif laisser un tel article en
vigueur dans votre pays
sans porter atteinte d'une manière
complètement disproportionnée au droit
de vos concitoyens donc c'est
effectivement qu'en fait le conseil de
l'europe qui rappelle à la france ce que
sont les droits de l'homme permet quand
même les choses en perspective on le
sénat il devrait remanier plus ou moins
cet article 24 mais oui c est que 24
quand on connaît notamment parce que oui
ça va concerner les gilet jaune n'est
pas que mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
dans dance concédé manifestation on l'a
appris au contact des gilet jaune et du
contentieux et gilet jaune de ce qu'ils
ont subi tout toutes ces années puisque
maintenant parle en termes d'années donc
effectivement vous avez un arsenal qui
va consister à dire on présume que les
forces de l'ordre sont bienveillantes et
on présume qu'elle ne feront jamais de
mal qu'elles ne permettront jamais de
fautes et si par malheur ils n'agissent
pas dans son flat vous n'aurez pas le
droit d'avoir des preuves de ce qu'elles
ont commis en terme de violences
notamment sur des manifestants
manifestants j'ai des jeunes et quand on
a vu comment tu ces vidéos ont servi
dans le cadre des procès notamment un
qui ont soit que les jets les jeunes
soient victimes soit ce qui était plus
souvent le cas qu'il soit incriminés on
avait effectivement ces images qui
étaient captés soit par la plaie ce soit
par des gilets jaunes eux mêmes ou par
des gens qui simplement qu'on est leur
téléphone et pouvaient un moment donné
être le témoin d'une agression et
violence extrêmement fortes contre des
gilet jaune ou contre les manifestants
ces images là c'était la seule preuve
qui existait deux
cette réalité qu'ils éteignent et parce
qu'il faut quand même pas oublier que la
réalité matérielle des violences qui
sont commises contre les jets les jeunes
et contre les manifestants c'est une
réalité qu'il n'y ait dans la plupart
des médias est évidemment est niée par
vernon en place on se souvient quand
même des noms de premier ministre sur le
sujet qui avait nié complètement
l'existence de violences à l'encontre
des manifestants
donc c'est effectivement manifestement
créer un outil qui dit vous n'aurez plus
le droit aujourd'hui simplement de nous
être violente et dans le cas des
manifestations puisque s'il se trouve
pas n'existe pas en droit et si vous
devez pas couler forcément ça veut dire
qu'on connaît donc une immunité totale
le gouvernement sait défendre son
article 24 heures mettant en avant la
nécessité de protéger les policiers ce
qu'il y a aujourd'hui vraiment besoin
d'un nouveau texte de loi de sept
articles 24 pour protéger davantage les
forces de l'ordre qu'elles sont connues
il existe d'autres pénale et si les
l'ordre sont effectivement sujette à
l'heure dans leurs activités ils
bénéficient j'allais dire comme tout le
monde et peut-être plus que tout le
monde d'une présomption d'innocence
donc c'est effectivement à celui qui qui
va rapporter la preuve de leur
culpabilité que revient ce travail là
donc ils sont pas plus mal protégés que
les citoyens lambda et c'est normal
qu'ils aient à rendre des comptes sur
leurs activités sur comment est ce
qu'ils se comportent dans le cadre de
manifestations est sûre effectivement
les violences qu'ils engendrent parfois
trop souvent on l'a encore dit tout à
l'heure dans le cadre des manifestations
je pense que c'est
c'est absolument inutile il existe déjà
un arsenal pénal qui est largement
suffisant sans créer une espèce de de
présomption d'innocence renforcé parce
que qui serait du coup on est
rétractable ce qu'on pourrait plus avoir
la preuve contraire donc on est dans une
prison c'est gravissime en droit pénal
avait du sol et c'est totalement inutile
et je dirais que c'est même très grave
parce que si vous voulez les forces de
l'ordre elles représentent quand même le
lien qu'il ya effectivement entre entre
le entre nos gouvernants
et nous et dire aujourd'hui que ces gens
là n'ont jamais à rendre de comptes sur
ce qu'ils font et ce qu'ils font subir
et autres ce que ça implique pour la
presse parce que ça veut dire à un
moment donné où est ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on met le curseur
parce que c'est un délit mais tu est un
délit qui est intégrée dans la loi
presse donc ça veut dire que non
seulement les personnes les particuliers
si je puis dire ne peuvent pas filmer
c'est celle des fameux dire que même
après c'en est privé donc c'est
extrêmement grave ni rien qui soit juste
ici dans cet article 24 et ça crée aussi
sur le terrain sentiment d'impunité la
part des forces de l'ordre ça ce qu'on
fait en tout cas en avant les
détracteurs de cette proposition de
sécurité globale effectivement parce que
tu avais moi j'ai pour ma part des
dossiers on appelle ces dossiers ce sont
des êtres humains des êtres humains qui
sont venus me voir qui était dg les
genoux des manifestants dans d'autres
contextes qui ont été victimes de
violences extrêmement lourde pour
lesquelles on a beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés à mettre en place des
actions parce que d'une part il faut
arriver à réunir des preuves et que en
dehors d'un j'allais dire effectivement
d'une vidéo qui prend la personne sur le
fait de la violence donc il faut déjà
que vous ayez une conjonction de chances
pour que quelqu'un ait filmé à ce moment
là et derrière il faut que vous puissiez
retrouver la personne qui est à
l'origine de la violence l'identifier et
derrière déposer une pelote voir faire
une citation directe si vous avez pu
identifier cette personne dont vous
voyez que les obstacles pour arriver à
obtenir justice pour des gens qui ont
subi des violences extrêmement graves
on l'a vu pendant toutes les
manifestations gilet jaune et je crois
qu'on l'a encore dit aujourd'hui à ces
gens là ils ont ils ont ils ont la
présomption déjà qu'on trouve dans les
faits donc si vous les priver de cette
réalité vidéo visuel le témoignage parce
que le témoignage il faut bien savoir
que lorsque vous êtes devant un
quelqu'un qui représente les forces de
l'ordre le témoignage de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas c'est pas partie des forces de
l'ordre et forcément quelques chefs qui
ne va pas être recevable en tout cas
probants parce que on va vous mettre pas
ça à quelqu'un qui a prêté serment qui
bénéficie donc d'une parole qui est
difficilement remboursables et qu'il ne
l'était aisément j'avais en tout cas ni
passe à quelques qui passe par là et qui
dit vivre l'amour j'ai été témoin de
violences j'ai vu cette personne qui a
agressé physiquement telle ou telle
personne ou telle circonstance cette
parole là
n'est pas recevable devant la justice
parce que elle est face à quelqu'un dans
les forces de l'ordre qui va vous dire
que c'est faux évidemment qui sera le
plus sous l'angle soutenu par les
personnes qui étaient autour de lui qui
font partie de cette même de ces mêmes
temps violent
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne alexandra alexandra dupuis
rappelle que vous êtes avocate au
barreau de la rochelle